and I've laid out instead an alternative
approach that suggests that we can
answer existence questions easily this
is my recent book ontology may be easy
where I try to revive a more
down-to-earth view of how to answer
existence questions I think you throw it
really quick before we're done all right
so ontology is easy on my view in the
sense that all well-formed
straightforward existence questions can
be resolved by straightforward
conceptual work and sometimes empirical
work so that is to say are there tables
you've all got the concept of a table I
presuppose I assume right have a look
there's one now okay we're done right
are there let's see so in some cases you
can do straightforward empirical work
sometimes it's harder empirical work are
there still Tilly ated woodpeckers in
the woods of Arkansas that's empirical
work it might take years to figure it
out but we know how to do it we don't
were out with it
you can also get straightforward consent
of conceptual arguments in some cases it
goes like this four numbers start with a
straightforward claim that no-one's
gonna dispute there are two cups on the
table but then you can infer from that
trivially it seems like that if there
are two cups on the table the number of
cups on the table is two so the number
of cups on the table is two so there is
a number namely two for properties I
don't got a Red Square ma'am so they did
right you started the ugh controversial
truth that the square is red infer from
that the square has the property of
redness and so conclude that there is a
property the property of readiness
possessed by the square alright this is
gonna go so what I argued then in that
book was that something's wrong with all
these so-called deep debates about
whether there really are numbers or
organisms or tables or whatever they're
answerable to straightforwardly to be
the subjects of sort of difficult and
deep philosophical debate and discovery
now the usual objection that was raised
to that claim with that simply makes
these this kind of philosophical work
too easy
it doesn't take account of why people
would have worried about this of what
some of the deeper debates of philosophy
are
so my approach is in a sense a return to
something like a conceptualist view
which means I also do have you can give
a greater length responses to the
worries about analyticity and external
series of meaning but at any rate where
are we seem to be left at this stage in
the discussion it's with a kind of
unpleasant awkward dilemma right how are
we gonna think of philosophy if we go
with the old school discovery view and
think of philosophers way back and they
would have in the pre-socratic times as
engaged in discovering what the world is
like what exists and what its nature is
we end up with these problems when a
conflict is common sense rivalry with
science a lack of convergence that might
seem to lead us into a kind of skeptical
torpor and the kind of epistemic mystery
about how we could come to have this
knowledge you could shift over to
something like the conceptualist
model and think of the work of
philosophy has engaged in conceptual or
linguistic analysis in some sense to be
further developed and it's been
developed in many ways but then again
the threats are this leaves philosophy
shallow and uninteresting just worrying
about our language or concepts seems to
be not worldly hey well rigid in
philosophy was the world not our
language or concepts my colleagues will
often say and you also have this sort of
lingering worry about whether you're
gonna get a new rivalry with linguistics
or cognitive science if what you're
really interested in is meanings so
neither seems completely appealing you
seem to be left a bit stuck is there
anything of value and interest left for
philosophy to do then it's both
plausible and worthwhile or should we
just give up a discipline that seems to
have become either implausible if you
take out on the discovery model or
shallow and dear relevance if you take
it on the conceptualist model that's the
threat and with that depressing thought
I shall leave you for a few minutes see
you in a bit did you know that the
Institute of arson ideas also has a
podcast philosophy for our times bring
you the biggest ideas from the leading
thinkers around the world every week
search for philosophy for our times and
subscribe today on your favorite podcast
platform SoundCloud or iTunes to make
sure you never miss an episode